today the las vegas sands corporation  reported their earnings for the first  quarter of 2021 las vegas sands operates  of course the  venetian and plaza while revenue is  still down  there are signs of recovery much of that  is happening on the weekend with  slot play approaching levels set back in  2019  last month sans announcing it was  selling its las vegas properties  and would be focusing their efforts on  resorts in asia  the increase in demand there has given  the company hope for its  well here properties overseas vegas it's  amazing busy here and demand is back i  mean the cow's gonna follow suit  vegas is still waiting for the return of  the group business but that's inevitable  i think china and the tower let's see a  slow gradual return in the second half  year could be very positive  the sale of the venetian palazzo and  sands convention center is expected to  close at the end of this year  the new owner is apollo global  management